just want to apologize for the way i
treated you right after your surgery you
know
i'll be there for you okay i'm sorry
michael keeps acting like i had some
choice about getting my surgeries
and he had no say that's not how it is
this is about my health michael it
wasn't that you were opinionated didn't
matter
i would have died i really believed that
because i couldn't hardly breathe with
my breasts
and my weight was getting bigger
for no reason it's hard for me to
understand all this
way over the phone and even i'm with you
there we
living together i will understand this
perfectly
then you should say that instead of
acting like that
forgive me
michael we need to step up to the plate
or it's time for us to separate
no no don't say that you're not
separating okay
what can i expect from you if i have to
have
another procedure you know i'm gonna
have to have skin
surgery i'm thinking about the facelift
what's going to change because i needed
someone there to
tell me it's going to be okay till this
phone call right here
i've lost 70 pounds and you
have it once said
oh you're looking pretty god that that's
an accomplished man you're doing a good
job keep it up baby
you make me feel like sure
i understand you after when i
i had to wait go into a damn store to
get groceries when i get groceries and
be told damn you look good for me
that's what my husband should have been
telling me you better close the eyes
because i [ __ ] their eyes my husband
ain't opening ears
it's open wide and clear like this
you doing this surgery which makes you
look
much more better healthy young and
sexy and beautiful to me i mean i needed
them compliments then
you didn't do it but michael you've got
to step up
i'll step over all you need to do is
stop that
man stop thinking that because you're
the african man
that yeah it's okay to do that it's not
michael
it's not and i don't care about the
cultural differences
men shouldn't treat women like that no
matter where they come from i'm sorry
baby okay
after talking to angela i understand
because of me
all the pain she had gone through and i
feel bad about it
i think it's a bad time to put my foot
down
as an african man just want everything
to
settle and uh no make peace again
i'll be there for you you know and show
up
oh what you are doing and i love you so
much
okay i love you i still love you but i
i just i just hope you mean what you say
because every time you say you mean
something you showed me different
actions are
bigger than words to me
you